the resurgence of vintage video games is
great for many reasons not the least of
which is the availability of new
equipment to play old games on modern
TVs seattle-based analog has
traditionally stood ahead of the
competition by releasing great-looking
consoles that offer best-in-class video
processing and notably nuanced
configuration settings and its latest
device the super NT is no different it's
a beautifully designed compact console
that at the moment is the best device
for playing original Super Nintendo
cartridges on HD and 4k TVs it's a
relatively expensive option at $189 but
if you obsess over minor details and
strive for authenticity the super antes
price tag is easily justifiable in
addition to Nintendo's own Super
Nintendo classic there are multiple sub
$100 HD enabled Super Nintendo consoles
to choose from nowadays from
manufacturers like hyper can and retro
'but while functional the retro and
retro trios of the world are consoles
designed on a budget with constrained
feature sets an outdated tech sure you
can in theory grow accustomed to
shortcomings like input latency and
improper video processing but accepting
these quirks doesn't diminish their
existence analog took a decidedly
different approach for its console that
eliminates these issues from the start
the Super NT offers highly configurable
video output with resolutions up to
1080p and near-perfect performance
thanks to the industry first FPGA
configuration under the hood in simple
terms an FPGA chip can when programmed
correctly replicate components like RAM
video processors and CPUs a process that
causes the FPGA to literally reorient
its circuitry in this case developer
Kevin Horton has created a seemingly
complete Super Nintendo on an FPGA a
feed no other individual or company can
claim generally speaking games played on
the super NT look and play exactly as
they should
albeit up scaled to resolutions beyond
the original systems native 240p signal
the Super interval output video at 480p
576p 720p or 1080p with suitable options
to cater to the peculiarities of games
designed for both NTSC and PAL standards
however the output resolution is only
half of the story once that's settled
you can dive into other menus to
configure the aspect ratio of game
screen adjust its position crop unwanted
portions of the image and manually scale
width and height to achieve your desired
look simulated scan lines are also
available
but rather than apply a filter over the
image the super antes solution operates
on the individual horizontal lines of
resolution so when you enable scan lines
in conjunction with a resolution that is
not a multiple of 240p such as 1080p
they lack complete uniformity the super
in Tal line options can be adjusted and
slightly improved but if you want to
play with quote unquote proper scan
lines your best solution is to stick to
480p or 720p with over 2000 Super
Nintendo games released across multiple
territories it's virtually impossible
for anyone to say with absolute
certainty that the Super NT as 100%
compatible with all games from start to
finish but in testing dozens of
cartridges we only had issues with two
games
Mortal Kombat 2 and a reproduction
cartridge of the unreleased English
version of rendering Ranger are - known
as Targa analogs answer for the moral
combat - issue to fix the bug in less
than 48 hours a new firmware came
quickly after analog reproduced the
glitch on its end and it's comforting to
know that a precedent has been set for
addressing and resolving incompatibility
issues in short order Targa on the other
hand remains an issue it simply won't
get past the publisher splash page
despite working fine and other
aftermarket consoles this was also the
case when trying to play the Japanese
version using a flash card on the super
NT rendering Ranger is known to be a
problematic game even for official Super
Nintendo consoles but analog promises a
fix is on the way in the near future of
note is the potential as hinted by
analog for an option down the road to
tailor the Super n T's fpga on-the-fly
to match Super Nintendo Hardware
revisions even among Nintendo's own
consoles these variations and processors
and coders would lead to rare instances
of glitches in certain games such as
rendering Ranger r2 so it's refreshing
to know that the super NT may have a
workaround for end-user troubleshooting
at a later date aside from those two
exceptions compatibility was otherwise
rock-solid during our tests including
games like Star Fox Mega Man x2 and
Street Fighter Alpha 2 which are
designed around traditionally
troublesome special expansion chips that
handle applications like 3d calculations
and asset compression there's also
native support for peripheral carts like
game genie and super Gameboy including
streaming audio which most Super
Nintendo clones struggle with the only
accessory you can count on not working
is the super scope a light gun designed
for and only compatible with CRT TVs
analog is currently developing a quote
unquote lag-free digital to analog
attachment for the super NT to support
CRT televisions the performance release
date and cost of the DAC remains to be
seen
on the outside the super NT is
straightforward a USB micro port for
power an HDMI port for AV output an SD
card slot for firmware updates and two
Super Nintendo controller ports
traditional Super Nintendo controllers
work exactly as expected and as analog
suggests you can also use wireless
controllers made by 8-bit dough which
now come in colors designed to match the
four color variants of the Super NT the
a potato controllers are convenient to
connect and charge offers surprisingly
low latency and feel almost like a
Nintendo made controller the one minor
issue is the d-pad which will only
occasionally move your character on
screen left or right when you'd mean to
press down should you inadvertently tell
your thumb though not perfect we like
the a pedo controllers a lot and only
wish the Super NT came bundled with one
it should be noted that even though you
won't normally have to tinker with the
8-bit doe wireless transmitter once you
started playing a game removing or
adding transmitters during gameplay can
occasionally cause a super entity crash
forcing you to power the console off and
back on
according to analog this is due to
related power demands coming from the
transmitter in the system detecting and
protecting the fpga from potential harm
thankfully wired controllers can be
connected and disconnected without
shutting down the system while there are
obviously a few quirks to keep in mind
the benefits of the super NTA are
outweigh it's relatively minor issues
there is simply no other console that
can play actual Super Nintendo
cartridges at 1080p without relying on
expensive video equipment and looking
beyond resolution the number of settings
at your fingertips makes it easy to dial
in the look you want for your SNES games
in a matter of seconds the Super NT is
impressive both inside and out and a
smart solution for anyone who strives to
see their favorite 16-bit Nintendo games
in their best light
[Music]